i was flying my drone and i got it stuck
really high up in a tree can you get it
back
like i'm fairly certain that drone will
never come down
i need you to either get that gopro back
or i need you to replace that gopro
untangled in the branches are you
serious yeah
yeah you've never crashed you've never
crashed though that's why they call you
no crash friends because they've never
crashed ever on any of your drone stuff
right no pressure why are you worried
about that weird weird thing for a guy
who's never crashed a drone before to be
worried about
you bring up an excellent point
so a few months ago i was flying my
drone in this empty park i was having a
good time and i decided to throw a gopro
on top of it i decided to fly through
this gazebo thing but i just kind of you
know forgot there's a huge tree in the
way so of course i flew right into the
tree and i've gotten my drone stuck in
trees before i've always been able to
retrieve them but this time i couldn't
figure out you built a retrieval drone
which is like a trunk
you can't find it it's like it's at the
top of this like 100 foot tree and i've
like scoured it i've looked through all
the footage and i still can't find it
but i know it's up there oh and there's
one of our studio gopro eights on the
drone store yo
they could fire you for that dude
that's like
that's destruction of company property
dude they'll write you up i think you
gotta mount a rescue operation dude no
man left behind it's like imagine the
following
it rains
it shorts your battery
you've now caused a forest fire you and
then when they go when the firefighters
go through the wreckage and the ashes
they're gonna be like what's this gopro
and they're gonna find on the back of it
it's a dress dude dude you're gonna get
us all put in prison you're not gonna
last long in prison
you gotta get this drone now i gotta get
that drone did you find it where'd it go
you know if i could find it that that
would be a big step up
okay update i am beyond excited freddie
inspired me to go looking for the drone
again and to my extreme pleasure i found
it it's right there that's not coming
down that is wedged up there that is
absolutely wedged up there that is not
gonna come down in a hundred years but
who knows maybe we'll try to get it down
at some point i have no idea how i have
to figure that out at some point
so a little birdie told me that ren lost
his drone he had a gopro 8 on the drone
that gopro 8 belonged to corridor well
he was using company property and now
that company property's gone missing
maybe i should talk to him first you
know like a good boss just talk talk
things through conflict resolution you
can't see it under the mask but i'm
frowning
so i went to go count the number of
gopro eights we have and it is the
craziest thing we're short by one i know
i don't want to say i lost it i made a
bad maneuver and i got it stuck really
high up in a tree it's it's so high up
there can you get it back i think i
could probably get it this weekend
no oh no no
i need it by friday two days from now
why
we have a node shoot
wait hold up i have to get it tomorrow
is what you're saying a gopro needs to
be charging with an sd card in it ready
to go i need you to either get that
gopro back or i need you to replace that
gopro which basically means buying us
another one
cool well i look forward to seeing the
gopro in the charging bay
uh friday morning
a day
okay so first things first we do have
today we do have today okay we should go
to that tree you dean and i can assess
the situation because i know where it is
but that's just the first problem solved
oh it's right there
it's got green and yellow propeller
blades which is like the worst thing to
have is propeller blades in a green and
yellow tree i found it yep
yep that's a drone right there now we
are officially on the same page we know
exactly where that drone is it's right
there that is so much more high up than
i thought it was do we can we shoot it
with something like shoot it out of the
tree
oh that was terrible never mind
we could climb the tree so that's the
other problem yes that could work trees
are climbable this tree
i would consider it if i knew for
absolute 100 certainty that there were
no spiders on this tree
i would consider it but then there's the
challenge of how this trunk is like six
feet in diameter
i could probably lay down and fit
entirely within it so obviously you'd
have to get some sort of gear uh some
sort of like harness system whip the
chains around
man i brought my mavic with me my mavic
air too and i'm gonna launch it up and
now that i know exactly where it is i
can fly right up next to it next nick's
getting on me because i've been keeping
this mavic which belongs to quarter at
my home and that's because we have three
of these things we had eight gopros and
now one's in the tree so all i'm saying
is just be careful don't get the drone
stuck in the tree again
[Music]
yeah it's right there
ah i see it i thought oh my god i
finally see it on camera so yeah um i
don't know how to get that thing out of
there though so the drone is pretty
close like it's it's on the edge of
falling off i feel like if we can just
hook one of those branches and just tug
yeah and just tug maybe we can shake it
out but then the problem is that then it
would land on top of this green theatre
and this is a little harder to get to
because i mean they're both hard to get
to that's fine
at least this you can climb it like i'm
fairly certain
without intervention that drone will
never come down this is something we
gotta figure out between now and
tomorrow morning or i have to pay for it
myself oh i got an idea we also have all
that net from my my net gun video if you
flew a length of net suspended from your
drone that's a sure catch on that branch
how would the net catch any of that dude
do you remember when i was making that
video how much the net was catching
every single thing around me we're not
trying to catch the drone we're trying
to catch the branch so that we can then
pull it or a slingshot we don't have a
slingshot but we have the condom guns
yeah with the arrow
we can do an arrow why didn't we do an
arrow we can do it now dude we could
just i'm bringing all the stuff okay so
arrow in a net a drone deployed net so i
guess when i get home i'm gonna have to
quickly model some sort of hook i'm
probably gonna print this out of the
same material i printed jan's finger
with that green tpu i can't afford to
fail those teslas aren't cheap man
why do you think i don't have 500.
[Music]
hey man
yeah long time no talk
yeah don't worry about the trial i'm not
mad it's okay it's fine i heard you've
been reinstated
you owe me a favor all right we're in
lost something that belonged to us and
he has to go get it back yeah rent city
is going to go take care of it but you
know what i think i need some
babysitting needs me to make sure the
job gets done
you can do it if i don't see that gopro
it's both of your asses all right you
make it happen counting on you
hello
i'm wesley from wesley and wesley
incorporated and i brought my assistant
my assistant companion mohawk marley
marley hey please don't turn your back
on me
i need us to be on point i wore the
special socks you asked me to wear the
socks and i put them on uh this is my
first day back on the job disbarred
that's how we're starting things off
that was the one time i failed niko
i'm gonna let you know it won't happen
again niko i'm here to retrieve a piece
of equipment that ren may or may have
not have lost or may have not lost is it
lost it's right there
you see that
it doesn't seem to be within my grasp
yet
yet yes okay yet i'm gonna win back
jake's trust he's trusting in me you
know so winning it back is all that
matters at the end of the day
damn so what's the best angle to shoot
at like directly up directly up so i'm
not going for the drone i'm going for
the main branch that it's on yes okay
yes because ideally we just get the
arrow over the branch and we can just
shake the branch and then the drone will
fall out i hope we don't lose this arrow
we have now confirmed that there is no
one in the vicinity i feel reasonably
confident that we are doing this as
safely as possible right now so we're
gonna execute on it let's go three two
one fire
oh
that was pretty close that's pretty
close that was pretty good pretty close
now the question is did it actually like
grab
anything not much no okay i need to go a
little bit to the right i think fishing
for drones
fire
frick
i feel like the poundage of this boat is
just under the power needed to get this
arrow up
ready yeah
oh no oh
we lost the arrow
this might not work
plan b i'm gonna hang a net underneath
the mavic we're gonna what
i've got to call jake to see if this
isn't it's just a simple
net mounted drone detachment system it's
by the books man do you read the books
that it's by it's by the book it's like
next to a book like by the book
yeah it was more yeah yeah
i'm nervous this plan can very easily go
wrong and we lose another drone
okay
sure
yeah
yeah i know i know i know please let me
step away from running you come close
and then we lost the arrow inside the
trees
okay i don't i don't care what i need is
you to get that drone out of that tree
okay because without that our client
can't prove his case you're right and if
we don't have a case we don't have a
client and if we don't have a client
then we don't have wesley and wesley we
just have wesleys if i have to climb up
there myself
by wesley i will i believe in you wesley
i believe in you
there's one more thing it's really
important what is that one more thing
today's episode is brought to you by
expressvpn oh my goodness is it really
yes expressvpn is one of the premier vpn
services out there okay they offer top
tier data encryption and ip masking
which allows you to hide your real
address which allows you to access
servers all over the world did you know
that i i do know that because i got
expressvpn myself that's right they're
consistently faster than almost any
other vpn service out there because they
have servers in 94 countries i mean if
they're not an expressvpn are they
really even a country probably not and
listen they also have 24 7 customer
support meaning that your questions are
answered within seconds rather than
within hours
you can utilize their service on any
device any device
and they were rated number one by cnet
the verge wired and tech radar
wesley where should they go
you better click that link that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v
corridor crew click the link in the
description to find out how you can get
three months free okay so i guess we
gotta get back to that drone huh yeah
back to the drone right now we're
cutting some uh fishing net
so what i've done is i've now attached
these hooks
to the net this might be the worst idea
ever no no no i'm with you and this will
attach to the drone one person will have
to kind of like veer off to the left
with the net string and another person
will have to veer off to this side with
the drone string if this thing actually
like works this will officially be the
jankiest last minute solution to
anything i've ever done in my entire
life
checking off
she's holding
oh god oh god wait wait okay good good
wait oh okay okay you're good you're so
close
he's so close
you got this man turn off okay okay i
need you to pull
pull pull
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
no
all right this is where this comes in
so we lost the drone um it landed on the
canopy here
let's go run
look at that thing
oh no this is not going to work it can
work i believe it can work i'm just
going to make a new net we'll give this
one more shot this is a whole adventure
and i felt i felt it when they said west
pull i was like i got this i'm saving
the day and then
what if we just put a string on the
drone and just fly the drone into it
there you go
so you're gonna try to land this you're
gonna try to fly the drone
with the string attached over the tree
hopefully without it getting caught up
landed on the other side of the tree no
i was just going to like fly it directly
into the branch as fast as i can wait
what it's just straight up squad
[Music]
this could cost me my job
we'll see
i'm gonna figure out the approximate
elevation that i need to be at to
actually get into the branches
and i'm just gonna go for i'm just gonna
like fold dude
i'm gonna approach it from this side
flying this direction it's it's more
open on this side so i think i have more
clearance just to go straight in on that
this works
this works you better subscribe and if
it doesn't you should subscribe anyway
so that you can see when we get it to
work i have now confirmed that there is
no one in the vicinity
[Music]
guys like i'm looking up at the sun
oh i see it there we go dude do you have
visuals i have visual i have it i have
you now oh we got park
okay i'm just gonna have to go for it
just go for it
did you get it
we got it we got it you got it we got
the string we got the string
oh we got it bro i looped it i flew
through the branch and it landed over
here okay okay okay
now come come near can you give me that
stick oh my god
all right i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for
it
[Music]
[Laughter]
i couldn't be happier
it's still up there but it's more
achievable now than it was before
the drone seems to be in one piece it
seems to be working just
yeah that's the fine drone that's the
wrong drone that's not the drone
i know
marley knows that the drone isn't down
yet i am actually proud of how absurdly
ridiculous that is and the fact that it
worked it's still stuck up here we can
just climb this down to cl i'm down to
climate dude down to climate center i
can climb it but there's no way in hell
i'm going to that is spider city yeah
you do have a slight fear of spiders
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
call nico and let him know that we got
it out the tree and that's all you're
going to say right mission was
accomplished as far as i'm concerned we
got it out of a tree and now it's in a
bush you have a certain amount of time
to get it out now oh yeah yeah we're
going to get out we'll get it out soon
so they have until tonight to get it
done or it's my ass like literally
my behind
gone my ass is gone i won't be able to
sit down i'll be standing up for the
rest of my life so guys
it's my ass so we're gonna come back
this evening after park works have
closed down because we're gonna climb
this thing it's a bit of a heist so we
have to make sure we're safe
we have to make sure we're
tactical
we got like actual steel like
like look at this
dude that's thick man now that i look at
it this is gonna be like going into a
jungle i'm it's literally gonna be like
a jungle man testing i want to just get
a
how does that feel this doesn't feel as
securely there
i'm just like a face full of plants
those vines didn't have as much
sturdiness as i had hoped when i was on
them some of them were giving me gives
so i do not see anything
oh
i do see it there it is so you're
directly it's literally in the middle
it's literally in the middle and oh man
the structure isn't going to collapse i
can still fall through and have one of
my friggin arms or legs down there do
you have a blade on you i do have a
blade cut yourself out i live by i study
the blade how big is your ladder dude
you can't lose another gopro no dude if
i lose the gopro on my face i am not
coming down from that tree without the
drone and the gopro
[Music]
anytime anyone's on the ladder we'll
have to have feet on the legs
we gotta go now we gotta go now i'm
gonna get the dog
you ready nick
yeah
oh god i know i know so i'm gonna have
my feet oh
holy crap it's super dark i know where
it is man i know where it is i think
you guys it's been great knowing you
nick you got this
it's just leaves all i see is branches
can you feel metal
everything i think that's metal is not
metal because this shit's so thick bro
is that it ah yeah okay i'm going full
tree now
there's a soccer ball there's a soccer
ball it's a soccer ball
[Music]
oh my god
how you feeling
untangled in the branches are you
serious
yeah
no no i'm good i'm good okay that
sounded bad though sorry sorry sorry
i'll say red alert if something's bad
did you see it
next go to your right am i right i think
straight to your right about two feet am
i right
you're getting close
nick it should be and it should be here
somewhere right yeah you're at the edge
nick don't climb any farther copy
where is it ren okay okay i am directly
above it right now copy
searching
i don't see the dang thing it's there
it's there oh it's right to your right
right to your right here right there
there it is
there it is
you got it come to papa baby
it's okay
it's in a prison it is get your knife
i'm getting it
[Music]
you got it
let's see if this baby still turns on
she doesn't turn on she's really really
dead oh god yeah now i gotta get you
home nick crawl back to where we were
yeah i'm crawling backwards by the way
this thing is dusty man this is what
five months in a tree will do to a drone
and a gopro
i can just chuck it yeah chuck it out
into the grass
oh this feels so wrong dude
oh my god i have not seen you in months
i have not seen you in months yeah okay
okay
oh your foots on it
oh that feels so good all right careful
careful careful we're almost there nick
careful don't twist too much just a
little bit further nick okay you're good
you're good you're good
cool
oh my god
the gopros yeah oh my god
here oh
it's light so much that's it bro
this has been in the elements for three
months
oh there's a spider on it get away get
away there's a spider there's legit baby
spiders on it oh i do see it yeah i do
see it so this drone has become
someone's home here you go
come on he's just a little guy
all right i got the gopro drones trash
oh my god
we got it cool dude nick i can't believe
you did that a little bit more than uh
we thought but it turned out to be kind
of fun once i was up there oh yeah you
said you found scored a free soccer ball
too from the 90s that's an ancient relic
dude i don't have to pay 500 bucks we
got the drone back
let's take the suniko
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well guys consider liking and
subscribing and uh leave a comment below
about who your favorite lawyer and
wesleyan wesley is see you in the next
one